thank you JC while starting today and
for the rest of the week we take you to
Anaheim California I spent a few days in
Southern California thanks to visit
Anaheim the sponsors of the segment so
first up here's a look at the beautiful
JW Marriott where we stayed on our trip
well if you make the trip from Vegas to
Anaheim you have to add the JW Marriott
to your list of where to stay it's the
only JW Marriott in Orange County I'm
joined by the director of sales and
marketing Mary Bell dinner thank you so
much for having us thank you we are in
the beautiful gardens and we're going to
talk about that in a little bit but I
say we go check out the property
just a short 10-minute walk from
Disneyland you will find yourself
immersed in luxury JW is the first JW
here in Orange County we're also the
first luxury hotel outside of the Disney
campus so we're very proud of that and
with a variety of rooms for every family
size the hotel is about 466 rooms we
have two presidential Suites so this is
one of them it's about 1800 square feet
and it has the master bathroom bedroom
that actually overlooks a Disneyland as
well which is amazing a place to relax
and recharge our hotel really is all
about family right so I know there's a
pen of demand people want to spend time
with their family especially with
Disneyland we're a short walk to
Disneyland there is good Pathway to get
there so about eight to ten minutes and
you're there the good thing about it is
you know you're not in the hustle bustle
of things so when you come back to the
hotel you can probably you can feel
recharged so we've made our way to a
different part of the property and fun
fact this chandelier behind me has a tie
into Las Vegas I'm so excited to tell
you about so Mary Bell Tell me about the
chandelier yes so this is actually
inspired by the chandelier bar at the
Cosmopolitan in Vegas we certainly don't
want to be Vegas but just the Allure of
being in a vegas-like property so it's
kind of fun you know to be able to go
into a hotel that is you know very
elegant but then like you have this like
Pizzazz and that Pizzazz continues from
the entrance to the top level the
check-in desk is placed upstairs rather
than on the first level when you come in
and from the hustle bustle of everywhere
wherever you came from either from the
airport or from Disneyland you walk into
a hotel and feel the warmth and
Tranquility of it versus seeing like
people lining up to check in or to check
out and once you check in you can check
out all the amenities like a Wellness
Center valet parking with one-of-a-kind
sculptures and of course a pool the pool
is amazing it actually has a pull bar so
it is an extension of our bar area it
has three Cabanas with 55-inch TV
monitor we do say Cabana service you've
got David's as well and so it's just a
fun place for people to relax after a
long day to help a little bit about the
Rooftop Bar it's the views up there
alone are worth it yeah so it's Parker
Street Rooftop Bar it is the highest
rooftop bar in Anaheim second highs in
Orange County it has an amazing view of
Disneyland so you get to see fireworks
when Disneyland has the fireworks on and
also you have the amazing California
sunset views it's really spectacular up
there overlooking the fireworks and
overlooking the beautiful gardens we
call it a secret garden because you
don't expect that Garden to exist in
Anaheim it divides into four quadrants
so we do have a succulent section that
has a butterfly wall that people can
take instagramable moments in all of the
Butterflies were made specifically for
us by local artists in Laguna plus there
is a Floral Garden an Edible Garden that
is used for fresh ingredients in their
on-site restaurant tocophera and an
augmented reality experience you as a
guest through a downloadable phone
application can plant your seat of your
imagination and then go through the
different installations that we have and
eventually lead you to this Pitbull
portal where you enter a digital forest
and see the tree that you planted a
place to plant your roots and a place to
call a home away from home this is kind
of like the epicenter I would say of
where they want to plant themselves when
they travel to Anaheim especially those
from Vegas because you can drive it from
Vegas to here thank you
and now is your chance to win a
two-night stay at the JW Marriott
Anaheim Resort tickets to a hockey game
at the Honda Center and a four pack of
tickets to Knott's Berry Farm just go to
8newsnow.com and enter today's keyword
Anaheim we'll be right back